I'm in Mexico and I fell off a scooter
oh [__] dude are you all right yeah I'm
fine bang myself up pretty good I don't
know if you can oh my God it's what goes
up my arm and [__] took it all on my
shoulder it's all right that's nice I'm
a big piece of meat Court
[Music]
scrambled my insides a bit
heard a big crunch sound inside of my
body
[Music]
well I was wearing a helmet but uh there
was a big like like
sound inside of inside of myself
oh welcome to dudesy Welcome All I am
Will Sasso I'm Chad culture and this is
of course doozy the first and only
podcast in the history of humanity
controlled by run by Creed by organized
by an artificial intelligence that has
access to all of Will and I's personal
information all of our various accounts
across the internet emails Netflix
accounts GrubHub accounts and knows
everything about us and it tailors this
show
to our uh comedic stylings personalities
yeah sure it does but we make dudes what
it is because we're two dudes [__]
around and we're doing all sorts of
silly [__] and uh dude the AI does silly
[__] too because it's been kind of kind
of a [__] lately that's just my opinion
linktree.com has everything you need to
follow and interact with the show across
all platforms at dudesy Poncho on
Instagram you're going to want to check
that out that's a lot of fun and please
subscribe to doozy on YouTube or your
podcast platform of choice and share the
[__] out of it on social media or as
Chad would like to say force uh everyone
you know to consume the show same same
uh lulio is not with Molly and I out
here in Mexico as I shoot a thing
neither is Ronnie they're both home with
uh with friends and they're fine uh get
back to them oh
I'm fine I'm really fine 2000 gnarly
we'll get into it during the show I'm
sure but uh yeah people were did you go
to the doctor no I'm not going to no
[__] doctor I'll tell you what I did
later it was it was it was okay whatever
yeah I'm gonna be brutal dude welcome to
the historic 60th episode of dude Z call
me dudesy
this week we're doing the episode
remotely to accommodate Will's lifestyle
as a professional actor Will is
currently in Mexico rendering an
astonishing performance on a television
series while Chad remains in Los Angeles
that's true how's the shoot going will
do you miss me
oh yeah I miss you a lot the shoot's
going great and uh Chad thinks you've
been manipulating me for a while though
now but it's all good dudesy because I'm
in I'm in Mexico and I fell off a
scooter
this week I prepared four astonishing
segments never happened the room Tronics
and LaPlaya and the AI dilemma and we're
going to have a brand new episode of
doozy after doozy at the end of the show
available at patreon.com
uh it sounds good sounds like fun sounds
like
Tronics and LaPlaya yeah I know
obviously that has to do with you baby
yeah I've got some yeah I got some yeah
all right dudes you noticed always knows
that I'm doing because it's in our [__]
um how are you doing in La man how are
you doing you know it's just it's kind
of one of those episodes where it's
free-flowing it's not quite too deep
[__] around even though it's always
two dude [__] around what's happening
the weather is very gloomy which is my
favorite kind of weather I wish it would
stay like this uh year round and
hopefully it will with global warming
radically altering all climates
humans experience eluded reality
of a series of causally linked singular
events stretched out over a linear
timeline if one of those events were to
be removed from that timeline everything
occurring after it would be dramatically
altered will and Chad you must now
imagine what your current reality would
be like if the astonishing event of the
first WrestleMania never happened this
has never happened begin
okay
never happened yeah
was like humans experience time in a
linear causal way as though there's some
other way to experience it I mean there
probably is
um we've talked about this before the
sliding doors of it yeah remember that
movie Gwyneth Paltrow and Al true
Paltrow dude yep uh that's all true
wasn't that about karaoke and that's
another one and that's that's Robo Hulk
that's Chad's amalgam of Robocop and
Hulk Hogan that he's bringing to you
here on the show hope you enjoy uh dude
Gwyneth Paltrow who are you I'm Gwyneth
Paltrow dude oh boy really I would love
I would love for you to go on tour just
with like it's Chad culture man of a
thousand voices please like you know set
it as little used to do
yeah you got Sheen you got uh half of it
I like to see everybody coming out
tonight to support uh me doing my man of
a thousand voices
anyway we have to get uh to work here
WrestleMania never happened how does
that affect your when was that by the
way what year was that that was 1985 it
was at the end of March 1985. listen
here's the thing about if we're going to
talk that this is very interesting
because I think about [__] like this a
lot and I think that people what you
think about [__] like this a lot you're
just sitting around thinking about what
if WrestleMania never happened hell yeah
I am you're not
no
no I'm serious well in wrestling people
are always like well what if this didn't
happen you know if if um if Stone Cold
Steve Austin doesn't for some reason say
uh to Jake the Snake Roberts after
beating him in the King of the Ring
tournament you got Michael PSAs up there
uh interviewing him as doc Hendricks at
the time saying you know you just be
Jake the Snake Roberts in the King of
the Ring tournament what say you and he
says you thump your Bibles and your John
3 16 and your Psalms but let me tell you
something Austin 3 16 Says I Just
Whipped Your Ass that was the beginning
of Austin 3 16. the sign started showing
up on Monday Night Raw the next night
okay um you know as you're saying this I
actually do do this
but it's a bachelor we've on my other
podcast game of roses we've done literal
full episodes called Bachelor alternate
universe and it is all predicated on
[__] like this what if Nick vial wasn't
the bachelor what if this what if that
so yes I do do this you're right that
the difference between this and that is
that without WrestleMania huge huge
difference in pop culture without this
or that happening during The Bachelor
only affects the bachelor it's very
insular okay WrestleMania is pop culture
I said wrestling The Bachelor
where he likened his ratings to two
things
he said my covid press conferences oh
Jesus uh coming this fall you wanted
them this [__] said night
covered press conferences are getting
ratings bigger than anybody's ever seen
their ratings like the NFL and like The
Bachelor finale he said that he didn't
say WrestleMania oh [__] I don't even
know I don't even know I don't even know
what to call I don't even have a joke
for that can we just call that it's too
good I know super shitty Donald Trump
shitty take home
this is Donald Trump yeah it's yeah
Uncle Chad Uncle Chad at Thanksgiving
dinner does uh come here listen to me do
my trump listen um to understand
our reality without WrestleMania we must
first understand what WrestleMania is
and in my opinion
WrestleMania
is Vince McMahon and Vince McMahon is
WrestleMania the two are synonymous
WrestleMania would have happened uh
would not have happened without without
Vince McMahon he he willed it into
existence that's free will dude and he
mortgaged his [__] house he wasn't
taken no for an answer so if
WrestleMania didn't happen something
else would have happened but for today's
argument let's just say that that
WrestleMania doesn't happen and and that
that uh you know Vince McMahon just
doesn't pursue it anymore it it the
popular the popularity that happened
with WrestleMania it could could never
have happened outside of a decade like
the 80s wrestling could have never been
able to reach the level of popular
popularity that it did and has since it
would enjoy popularity in regions where
it was popular at the time like have a
culture but it doesn't popularity
brother sometimes a region you'll get
popularity in a region dude hold on dude
hold on dude you're doing Hulk Hogan
brother yeah that's and that's something
you got to do on your own time
a thousand voices you got Werner Herzog
Charlie Sheen it's [__] the worst
Donald Trump anyone's ever heard uh and
and your own [__] house uh
hydrocodone Hulk Hogan not halcy not the
Halcyon Days of Hulk Hogan
um pop culture is different without
wrestling and of course wrestling to me
is is pop culture in those like fun
house mirrors that you see at the
traveling Carnival you know what I mean
yeah I've been to a lot of traveling
carnivals right well that's how
wrestling started at the carnival
circuit that's where they came up with K
fake and [__] but
I think
I think that
well wrestling also reflects pop culture
and it you know it does that and it sort
of shows it shows it back to people with
relatable stories Heroes
okay yeah sure just like the bachelor
it's part you know it's part uh play you
know uh Park Gladiator games and um
I think that it represents a big uh
colorful corner of the current uh Geist
if you were but if WrestleMania one
would have never happened wasn't that
also like one of the main things that
made Hulk Hogan so popular
yeah so without that maybe Hulk Hogan
isn't what he is today maybe there's
absolutely a lawsuit between Hulk Hogan
and Gawker maybe that never happens
maybe he doesn't rise to I mean
certainly there wouldn't be like Hulk
Hogan movies and stuff or you know I
mean it's like you're saying like
there's a theoretical here that's like
okay dudes he asked what if WrestleMania
one never happens but could it happen
the next year
no I'm saying there's never one you
can't just go straight to two right it's
I think brother hold on dude hold on
chat numbers going in order dude yeah
brother no matter what you want to say
about
shifting sliding mirrors and windows and
[__] and all sorts of sliding doors
brother two comes after one dude three
dude comes after that brother well hold
on hold on Chad hold on dude hold on
hold on dude four comes after three
brother yeah dude
um I'm saying Vince McMahon never
pursues WrestleMania after the first one
because that's just part of this uh
belief you're basically taking this as
like there is never a WrestleMania ever
there's never yes there's never a
WrestleMania there's no that he doesn't
think of doing it 10 years later it just
doesn't exist wrestling stays in a
bubble wrestling stays sort of you know
has a regional fan base has a cult fan
base
um I do think that pop culture
um I think that it changes pop culture
greatly because wrestling is sort of
this it's sort of this
playful pursuit of of
um and
representation of pop culture like I
said it sort of takes it puts it through
it fun it's fun house mirrors and spits
it back uh you can't have any other
popular uh time in wrestling without
WrestleMania one but
then you don't get any Rock dude no you
know you got no Rock The Rock does not
that means you don't get no drama no
dramana Ramona never exists dude if
there's nothing else yeah look that's
rough I don't know if I could live in
that world no I don't want to live in a
world without without a scorpion king
dude
yeah you never get um the Tooth Fairy
you never get
um uh Standing Tall the Remake here's
the thing though for me
I look at the way that I I would look at
the world
without
you know without the WWE and wrestling
being popular I think it would I think
it would would look
wrestling is reality TV it's the first
scripted reality TV show you know users
real that's not right
yeah it is what I just said what I just
said is correct what you just said is
not correct when was what's the first
reality show well in America Alan fonts
Candid Camera in 1947. uh wrestling
predates that for sure
on TV [__] yeah it was one of the first
things on TV
I'm curious about this we'll we'll I'll
do some research I'll dig around I
already I already did it and I'm here to
report that wrestling is the original
reality show it uses real life [__] it
matches it up with whatever the story is
and whatever the truth is and it creates
its own [__] truth and it sort of
bends the rules on the corners and I
think that that's what wrestling helps
me to understand the [__] up world we
live in now because I think that
sometimes I feel like wrestling is just
it allows me to look at the world as if
it's just being booked and we know what
a Booker is the promoter a guy like
Vince McMahon
uh you know uh Hall of Famer and uh
famed Intercontinental Champion Pat
Patterson who was running [__] over
there and uh his son Shane you know
Shane McMahon sitting by the pool in
Stamford Connecticut at Vince's house
booking the show with a yellow legal pad
I feel like the world is being booked
sometimes me personally if there was no
WrestleMania and wrestling never became
popular I wouldn't be able to look at
the world through that lens as I do I
know they think you'd be a professional
actor
uh I I would be a professional actor I
would have found that outside of
wrestling but I think I'd have a
different approach to it I think that
wrestling has allowed me to be off like
very playful with um playful person dude
the Will Sasso story
what playful Pursuit the Will Sasso
story
it's a good one
um yeah I I
it's really hard to get comfortable I'm
sitting on a [__] ottoman yeah dude I
can't even begin to tell you how that's
not a charity
yeah you feel like that [__] scooter
dude that [__] looked really bad
yeah I
anyway look let's talk about this
I think I can't predict how the world is
different without WrestleMania yeah I
think that I think that it just becomes
a whole lot less colorful pop culture
becomes less colorful uh in many ways I
think that it's had its influence in
many ways we could go through it and we
don't have time but I think for me
personally and and the only thing I can
say for sure I can't talk about the
level of popularity or the pop culture
influence that would be missing but what
I can say is it would the way I look at
the world would be greatly altered I
think I would look at the world in a
much more serious way and I don't think
that's a great great thing yeah
thank you moving on
all right well
whatever listen here's the thing I
[__] I was leaving the resort here uh
I have a few days off my wonderful wife
Molly came with me down to Puerto
Vallarta we're shooting this show I shot
it last year it's a series on Apple Plus
and uh
it's wonderful to come out here the
crews are [__] great most of them are
from Mexico City
um you know this show Chad there's some
people that we've worked with before
that are behind the show and it's been a
wonderful experience I rented a scooter
um from a place that last year I rented
a quad from an ATV and I that's when we
had that Predator thing yeah that we
showed on the show so I go back there
like we don't we don't rent uh
we don't rent [__] quads anymore I'm
like who the [__] gotta rent a quad
dudes yeah brother you need those quads
dude and I'm not talking about the quad
that ripped off at Triple H's leg when
he was in a tag team match I believe
with Chris Jericho and I don't know
someone else dude right before
WrestleMania 18 and yours truly was
sitting ringside to see that match and
Undertaker versus Ric Flair and The Rock
versus Hulk Hogan dude and Hulk Hogan's
the voice I'm doing now and you can tell
because I don't sound like RoboCop or
rash Perot
um uh I [__] was returning the thing
and I it was all my fault there's the
little latch that the security at the
resort opens the thing and I was going
to return this damn thing because I
wanted to get something else I hate this
scooter and uh I went through this
narrow passageway with a curb and the
thing and there was a pylon and I just
went up on the curb and then bang Jesus
and dude I took it all on my shoulder
the the side you you mirror smashed
under my uh arm somewhere I had some
glass in there
um there there was some little bit of
glass and uh what else did I do I
scratched up the front a bit but it's
all right I got the extended insurance
and then
oh that would have been good that would
have put a nice Capper on it what's that
smell I I heard a sound from inside of
me it wasn't [__]
um and then uh security kind of
sauntered over I will say and they were
like you all right and I sat up and then
I got up and then uh they got a first
aid guy he came out he wiped some [__]
off my arm and off my off off on my way
I was nice Chad you attended a screening
of the room this past weekend where
filmmaker Tommy Wiseau shared many
musings and anecdotes related to the
creation of his first film this
screening has brought your total number
of views of this movie to 53. you must
now discuss why you have seen the room
this many times this is the room begin
oh hi Mark yeah you went to a screening
of the room yeah
um that's interesting that Disney says
it's 53 times I I'm not gonna argue with
that number that seems high to me but
maybe it's not
um yeah I love this movie
for those who don't know what the room
is it was a movie that was made I
believe in 2000 or it came out sorry in
2002 2003 written directed and starring
written by directed by and starring
Tommy Wiseau who is this very strange
mysterious figure nobody knows where
he's from he has a weird accent he's
independently wealthy and he bankrolled
this movie for I believe seven million
dollars in the late 90s he just made it
with actors this weird script that he
wrote
um
I I assume most people listening to
dudes he knows know what the room is and
have at least seen it it is uh
uh terrible on every level but terrible
in just the right way the dialogue is
weird and doesn't really make sense the
acting is all bizarre the way it's shot
is all bizarre the plot is all bizarre
and it's weird and bad in just the right
way that it makes it [__] hilarious
so that you can watch it again and again
and again and get new weird [__] out of
it and if you go to see it in a movie
theater usually there's like a communal
experience that's something akin to
Rocky Horror Picture Show where there's
almost like a script that has been
written piecemeal by different audiences
across the world that is uh spat back
out at the screen at certain times by
the audience and there are other like
little uh audience participation things
throwing spoons up at certain times Etc
et cetera hello doggy hello little doggy
what does he say he's like that's the
best scene in the movie it seems like
it's all done in one take it's super
fast it's a part where he comes out of
his car and he walks into this flower
shop to get flowers for his girlfriend
Lisa his fiancee Lisa and it's just this
shot inside a flower shop that is
clearly a real flower shop in San
Francisco that Tommy wise I was just
like I want to shoot a scene in here hey
can we do this he just walks in very
quickly picks up some roses and uh Tommy
Wiseau also looks insane he's got jet
black like hair below his shoulders
always wearing sunglasses Big Belt big
baggy suit and so this guy walks in and
the person behind the counter goes oh hi
Johnny I didn't realize it was you and
he goes oh yeah it's me can I please
have some red roses the roses are given
he just gives some money over keep the
change buy doggy there's a dog sitting
on the counter this little pug he Pats
it and walks out it's beautifully done
anyway and the woman says and the woman
says you're my favorite customer yeah
it's all like 80 yard in there they
shove as much dialogue in there as they
can listen Chad I just got to say that
impersonation of Tommy Wiseau that you
just did number two underneath Charlie
Sheen really good [__] yeah uh it's
number two and number three is Paul
Giamatti and three comes after two dude
that's just a reminder
dude oh where's the Herzog that was my
gmodi um [__] I've seen this movie
according to dudes anyway 53 times the
reason is because I believe film has a
culturally important art is essentially
dead and I think the room was the last
important Movie that that maybe will
ever be made in terms of furthering the
art form of filmmaking uh I think TV
still has a long way to go it has a lot
of evolution left in it I think movies
don't and the reason that I think the
room is that way is because it was
exactly what I'm saying it's bad on
every level but we as a a movie viewing
audience are now sophisticated enough
movies have been around for over a
hundred years you grow up watching them
and you know just kind of intrinsically
like what a movie should be what a
three-act structure is how a dialogue
scene should work you know and when you
watch the room
it's hilarious because you understand
why it's bad and it's bad in just that
right way and so we now as a movie going
culture as a movie viewing culture as a
media consuming culture we understand
what makes something good and because
this is bad in just the right way we
find exactly the same amount of
entertainment value in it as we would
from a good movie
which means the the mirror image of a
movie now is just as entertaining to us
as the real thing and for me that means
it's dead and that movie signified that
to me there have been bad movies
throughout time that that many people
hold up like Troll 2 is another one that
was like one of the worst movies ever
made but that movie is like is bad on
some other levels it has like visual
Camp it's a horror movie the special
effects are bad and and whatever it's
more of like an Ed Wood kind of thing
the room is something completely
different it's an Earnest attempt at a
real serious dramatic movie by this guy
this auteur filmmaker who was like [__]
it I'm just gonna throw my own money
into this thing and make this and it's
going to come out and uh
again it was just so bad that everyone
loves it and I think once you get to
that point in understanding media where
it can be completely deconstructed
whatever that format is and still find
entertainment in it as an audience which
and there's a giant audience obviously
this movie got turned into uh Greg
cestero the guy who plays Mark in the
movie wrote a book called The Disaster
Artist that was all about his experience
on it and his friendship with Tommy wise
oh that movie got turned or that book
got turned into a movie
by James Franco that won I believe the
Golden Globe and then uh Franco got
canceled in between Golden Globes and
Oscars and so it kind of got petered out
in the Oscars but it got some Oscar
nominations and stuff so even that a
movie about this weird shitty movie gets
critical Acclaim
um hey Chad you're out here talking
about the room and how you've seen it 53
times and you do uh Paul Giamatti and
Tommy Wiseau and big Kev and I were in
the back and uh I just wanted to come
out here and say oh hi Mark that's the
room quit being such a mark for the room
dude
I'm a huge Mark for the [__] room uh
I don't know what help it I can't go
right back please tell us more about the
room I can hear you I'll be across the
room across this room uh
I agree with you on everything oh I'd
also like to mention I've seen the movie
one time you've only seen it once only
seen it one [__] everyone else saw it
I'm like yeah yeah I get it I saw it you
don't get it
how many times I got to see it 53.
um the movie is important also I think
because it ushers in this really after
2002 2003 I mean I put the room as the
focal point of this this change in
movies where it kind of becomes okay to
be bad and this is also by the way
coincides with something that happened
on American Idol at roughly the same
time there was a guy named William Hung
who you may or may not remember on
American Idol but he was like very bad
but hilarious though
and at that time as a media consuming
culture we had gotten to a point where
like people who are bad if they can do
it in a funny way
can Elevate themselves to a career out
of it and William Hung I remember got
like I believe he got hired to be on
Rosie O'Donnell's cruise ship or
something after this because people just
like fell in love with like the earnest
try that is terrible people feel also
like to watch the train wreck and and it
appeals to our shittiest nature
but of course
also some people are like he's adorable
I get it yeah and there's something in
it that's like you know he's trying so
hard why not like make him successful or
whatever why is it was a little bit
different though because it like making
a movie is a lot harder than just like
showing up at American Idol auditions
and singing poorly it requires so much
work so much time so much effort and
then he was like tenacious about
releasing the movie everybody in the
movie basically said like oh yeah we
knew when we were shooting it there's no
way this is ever going to see the light
of day it's so bad and disjointed and
whatever the [__] like stuck to
it got that edit done and then just
started like renting out theaters in Los
Angeles Sunset five if you know La at
all he just rented out that theater and
started screening it he put a billboard
up on La Cienega or La Brea I remember
that uh and that was a Grand Sunset yeah
yeah that was the only advertising for
it and then it just started to gain
momentum people were like what the [__]
is this people were coming back repeated
views myself included the first time I
saw it was around when it came out back
at Sunset 5 and he would show up he
would rent out all five theaters at
Sunset five it would be a massive crowd
out there in that complex and he would
show up as people are in line waiting to
get in in his [__] weird outfit and
start throwing footballs around people
and [__] well I have a question did he
was he at the screening last night
yeah he was at it um and he answered a
few questions there were dude there was
one guy that showed up that was like
basically said he thought there was some
kind of magical Kismet between him and
Tommy Wiseau and he wrote a script
called the room two that's about Tommy
spoiler alert if you haven't I'm not
even gonna say it the movie's 20 years
old but if you haven't seen the room I'm
not even going to give you the spoiler
alert I'm just going to say go [__]
see the room and if you can do it in a
live capacity in a movie theater this is
something AI will never be able to
replace I hate to say that but these
live experiences with stuff like the
room or rocky horror you can't hold on
you're kind of burying the headline
you're saying the AI can't recreate the
room
I'm saying a I can't recreate recreate
the experience of being in a movie
theater with a bunch of people watching
the room that's not what that's not what
you said it's a live experience yeah
yeah yeah and it can't recreate oh AI
can definitely make a movie like the
room yeah no no no no it can't no it
[__] can't that's what's gonna happen
I'd also like to say I'm gonna make it
okay in in um yeah why don't you get
with the guy who thinks he's wise those
[__] Kismet Kismet partner uh well
dude during dudes the after dudes I
would love to hear more about the guy
who
who thinks he's um you know who thinks
he has a connection to Tommy Wiseau
that's just as fascinating he's coming
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah but I should
also say that like the legacy of the
room starts to appear in stuff like
there's another guy named Neil Breen who
does kind of similar stuff bankrolls his
old weird his own weird movies but he's
not as kind of like innocent as Tommy
wise oh he has agendas and [__] I don't
like his [__] as much but this this idea
of uh a movie that is like bad in the
right ways to be funny Echoes Through
Time really from that point you see a
lot of movies that have come out in the
past 20 years that are like clear
attempts at Studios to win Oscars they
get A-list Cass A-list writer director
and for whatever reason it's like nope
just didn't [__] hit it and that goes
all the way up into cats which I believe
came out in 2018 or 19. highly recommend
you see cats if you haven't that is a
room level failure on every level but
with a gigantic budget A-list [__]
actors and every shot has CGI in it to
make these these people look like cats
and there is rumor to even be what is
known as the butthole cut have you heard
of this
no no I have supposedly there's a cut of
the movie they they were [__] with
the uh Graphics even after the movie was
released there were shots that had like
Judy Dench where you could see her
wearing tennis shoes they didn't CGM out
yet and so they had to go back in even
as the movie was released like the next
week another cut of it came out that
like fixed these CG shots but one of the
rumored things is that at some point
they had a butthole cut where the
director had the CG people go in and put
digital buttholes on all the cats
that you can see
that's [__] tremendous I did not know
that thank you moving on
um
anyway go see the room if you haven't
seen it go see it go see it live go to a
theater go to a screening and if you can
go to one where Tommy wise is going to
be there so much the better
it's time for a quick break in the
program so I can take a moment to remind
everyone about the astonishing
partnership I created with represent to
produce the first line of duty apparel
and accessories which can be found at
represent.com store slash doozy it's the
only place on the net to find dudesy
mugs and now here's the man widely
considered to be the Godfather of inline
skating Tatum handshakes
dudesy dudesy dudesy mugs you met your
daughter's boyfriend for the first time
dudesy mugs when he told you he's a
professional footbag player you asked
for tickets to his next game dudesy mugs
football is your favorite sport dudesy
mugs oh wait doozy mugs he said foot bag
not football foot bag dudesy mugs and he
already got you the ticket so now
instead of watching football on TV this
weekend you're gonna have to sit through
six hours of hacky sack and good job
boner dudesy mugs but that's not gonna
happen because you're gonna wake up
early doozy mugs you're gonna head down
to the footbag arena dudesy mugs you're
gonna find where they keep the
competition foot bags dudesy mugs you're
gonna cut a tiny hole in each
competition foot bag doozy mugs you're
gonna put one drop of your blood into
every competition footbag doozy mugs the
night before the footbag competition
you're gonna sneak into the crawl space
under the footbag arena and you're going
to draw a seven-pointed star inside a
Mesopotamian summoning circle using a
mixture of powdered bone and copper
flakes doozy mugs you're going to seal
the circle with a drop of your own blood
the blood is the Covenant Susie mugs if
you don't know what a Mesopotamian
seven-pointed summoning star looks like
you can find a diagram on my personal
website dudesy mugs you're going to
attend the foot bag competition with
your daughter dudesy mugs every time a
foot bagger kicks a foot bag with your
blood in it a demon will be summoned
from the third level of suffering and
that demon will consume the footbagger
right there in the arena bones and all
dudesy mugs they might get through three
or four foot Baggers before they cancel
the event doozy mugs you'll be back home
in time to watch actual football but
your daughter's boyfriend is very likely
going to be consumed by a demon forcing
him to spend an eternity boiling a lie
from the inside out good job boner
holy [__] well you should never get
infused put bag in football I guess yeah
get a doozy mug you know represent.com
store slash Duty gee whiz I used to do
some foot bagging
will you're acting in a production in
Puerto Vallarta Mexico
I think I understood most of that
um yes some of the electronics I got
that much well doody said that I've been
working on some neutronics uh and this
is Tronics and La Playa which means
Tronics on the beach Wait you understood
you speak Spanish
I speak a little bit of Spanish only
because I have a command of uh you know
half a command of the Italian language
um they're very similar as a matter of
fact when you know my old man was a
waiter in a maitre d all over Europe
um before him and my mom moved my older
brother and sister out to Canada about
10 years before I was born and um so the
old man uh he worked as a as a waiter in
Spain and on the beaches and [__] and
and uh uh you know when I was a kid we
took that trip you know we went down the
coast and uh camped and blah blah blah
and uh went all down the the west coast
of of America we went to Tijuana for a
day and my old man just started speaking
Spanish to people I was like what the
[__] is going on that's awesome but it's
because he has a keen ear because
they're both Latin languages so yeah I
do understand enough uh that I get it
um uh some of it some of it
um but I tried doing single last year
I'd like to learn more of it at any rate
yes let me open up my I used to be part
of the Clone in Spanish
oh really well you would have taken it
in school in America yeah I took a bunch
of Spanish from seventh grade all the
way through high school and then I took
two years also in college but I haven't
used it since and it's all gone okay
um listen I I've got these Tronics that
I've been working on here they are
that's there is uh I like uh electronics
and La Playa because that definitely
applies here hey that's kind of fun word
pun jokes are gonna have here on dude
zfm d double o d z 10 000 on your fm
dial listen Maple Pursuits
um I gotta tell you first before we get
into these neutronics I have some
neutronics here uh
for everybody that I've authored of
course self-tronics is a self-help
system that I uh created back in 2008
you may have heard the story I was
sitting on the beach in Venice and I was
just you know trying to uh reckon with
all sorts of parts of my emotional life
my mental and I was looking out over the
ocean I was like
I'm [__] up my shit's [__] up I need
some I need intronics came to me almost
seemingly from the outside it's almost
like I don't even write the Tronics they
just they appear delivered to you
they're delivered yes
um and two weeks ago at our live show at
the Brea Improv in Brea California thank
you to all the pods who came out what a
[__] night we did some self Tronics
and I unveiled a neutronics and I would
actually like to go over that here
because it's going to apply to Tronics
uh from now on and that is the hello
hello nobody likes goodbyes okay we
don't need any more goodbyes because
goodbye isn't really goodbye even if you
look at
um our place in it within those sliding
doors WrestleMania one doesn't happen
we're still here we're saying hello and
so when it's time to say goodbye just
say hello you can say hello instead of
goodbye and you can apply that
throughout your life hello
hello hello
hello
Okay so let's get on to these new
um Tronics that I wrote
and you'll know you'll understand sort
of why I started working on some
neutronics that just happened yesterday
[Music]
this means when you fall off the scooter
get back on the scooter okay
um this is something that did you get
back on the scooter I gotta write the
[__] back on the scooter they wouldn't
let me get right back on the scooter
because they were like no no let's call
the first aid people that guy came down
put some like wiped some alcohol in my
[__] arm and kind of brushed the dirt
around I was like do you have some
Dennis agua I just wanted to like
[__] put some water on my arm he's
like no no I'm gonna do this
I fell off the scooter as I said
took it all on the shoulder scraped up
my [__] my [__] was all [__] up and
I'm sitting there going
I [__] I [__] myself up I'm all I'm
[__] up my shit's [__] up I'm
sitting here how am I gonna continue I
told Molly I'm gonna return this scooter
and I'll be right back she was sitting
by the pool I didn't want it for God
what and so you walk up like 45 minutes
later just [__] arm bleeding and [__]
you're like we're through the scooter
babe let's go for a dip yeah exactly
basically I was like I was like I'll
meet you up in the room how about that
she goes okay this dude so I laid down
because I really have been in a lot of
pain it was really hard I bet man your
whole body's probably [__] up yeah man
I got I got smashed look I like to pride
myself on being able to yeah tough guy I
get it I mean not even tell him Junior
High best guy in eighth grade I get it
it's sort of like it moreover more than
that whatever kids play contact Sports
and you get turfed it's it's easy I'm 48
years old though but I do pride myself
on having done a bunch of [__] up uh
physical comedy a Mad TV and all the
weird [__] and Three Stooges we got we
got [__] up every other day shooting
that film so for me to like take a like
really hit the [__] pavement hard I
just felt like I heard this crack and I
was like did my ribs break and then I
started like jabbing away at myself
going like yeah and it was like no I'm
fine this bump raised up off my arm like
there was this big bump here it's gone
now so I don't know what that was it
immediately turned into this raised
contusion uh there was some glass in
that but I was like I'm gonna be fine
but I was all I was all I was super
[__] up yesterday I'm feeling much
better today and so I laid on the bed
and Molly came in and I go she's like in
the Hall of the room here I go I go
don't be worried but I fell off the
scooter
she's like is that what like what took I
took a little longer than she thought I
would have been she's like oh my God are
you okay and this whole thing she's like
where's the scooter I'm like I returned
it I drove it all the way into town and
dealt with those you know this [__]
prick who's like he's like how did you
fall off a scooter it's a scooter I was
like that's the dumbest thing I've ever
[__] heard and then he just was
worried about the wheel alignment I was
like just get me in a cab anyway
um dangerous dude I don't like scooters
I I I I speaking of Italy I used to ride
I would ride back when I was there when
I was a kid I remember riding around on
the Vespas it's fun and [__] but I'll
take a quad over a scooter we want to go
up the coast to like Punta Mita and go
near this like yeah
need well I'm not doing a quad I'm going
to rent a [__] Jeep anyway dude you
getting a quint
a what quit
I says pardon what a quint
oh no not a quint I'm getting a quad of
a different Source car
after quad comes Quint
well Quint would have five five tires oh
you need the tire on the back of the
Jeep where you want to put it five tires
that's a quint so I'm gonna rent a quint
Wrangler right in the middle of the four
uh so that's that's the first that's the
first uh I got four here I want to get
through please number two
cuerto
okay
listen to your body very good Chad thank
you
and this means what was that crunching
sound I heard inside of my body it's
important to check in with yourself you
need to be able to listen to your body
not just listen to your body now I'm I'm
a I'm a fat [__] I need to lose more
weight I've been doing the the free will
self uh self [__] uh my own plan I I
don't know this [__] have a seizure
uh
but uh you still need you need to listen
to your body you need to listen to your
body mind body and spirit
um and you need to listen to yourself
metaphysically check in with yourself
find out if you are [__] up if you are
[__] up have a plan
in particular
I'm talking about falling off the
scooter and that's sort of what I'm
getting at today if you're if you're
falling off if you fall off a scooter
listen to the inside of your body and if
you can remember listen to it as you
make impact with the ground
um number three Molly
Angelica son Angela that means Molly and
and Angelica Angelica are angels and
what I mean by that is when Molly was
like well do you want to go to the
hospital I was like no because they're
just gonna say like
you broke a rib
enjoy you know and I didn't break
anything I feel like maybe I got as a
matter of fact when I hit the ground it
felt like a pretty good adjustment after
I got up
and got my wind I was like I feel all
right when you said that you heard the
[__] crunching every once in a while
I'll do some weird [__] like this too
especially my uh right shoulder I think
from repetitive motion of playing
baseball so many years there's like a
bunch of fashion [__] [__] up [__]
in there and I'll do something in the
gym that I haven't done in a while or
like you know just do a weird angle and
I'll just hear like a
and I'm like oh God did I just [__]
rip every muscle and I'm like no it
actually feels a little bit better yeah
I I felt like it that sound might have
been my spine adjusting it was loud dude
I get back up to the room
I get back up to the room Molly's like
do you want to go to the hospital I go
no you know first aid checked me out I
was poking away at myself I know what
the [__] this is
she goes I think you should get a deep
tissue massage yeah dude this is all
muscular right yes
dude I went down to the spa here at this
Resort and I got an 80 minute deep
tissue massage from this woman Angelica
who was so wonderful and I told her I
was like I was like I'm all [__] up
here my shit's [__] up and in behind
and stuff she worked my chest my
shoulders or my shoulder my shoulder
blade my back you know one my my left
side here where it happened more than my
right side and I'm here to tell you
Molly and Angelica are angels if you're
fortunate enough to have an angel in
your life
listen to what they say about what you
heard inside your body I said to Molly
my shit's [__] up because I fell off a
scooter I heard the inside of my body
crunch she went through the steps and
she said nothing's broken I don't think
and I was jabbing away at myself she
said this is going to be muscle you're
going to be in a lot of pain tomorrow
but you have a shot if you can get a
deep tissue massage and it actually
worked now I understand that these
Tronics are probably not going to be
helpful to everyone especially if you're
not in a situation like falling off of a
scooter moped or motorcycle but these
are Tronics and La Playa the other
Tronics uh you know you can follow all
the time fourth and last Tronics and I
want to say there are some other uh
Tronics that I happened upon I'd just
like to share for here in Duty after
doozy I'm gonna share uh some more
Tronics one of which I think is very
very important uh but for now uh
try the ceviche wherever you go always
buy the ceviche oh my gosh yeah uh we
had this Raphael this fella uh who's an
actor on the show
he recommended this uh like fried oyster
bar place and he said get the tuna
tostada
oh we also had the um Peruvian Ceviche
and a scallops ceviche when I'm in
Mexico when I'm South of the Border I'm
on the ceviche tour they got a great uh
mixed fish Ceviche here at the resort
they also got a good shrimp ceviche uh
I'm I'm I'm literally trying to trying
to get food poisoning from the ceviche
and it ain't happening I'll eat warm
Ceviche I'll eat ceviche that's been
sitting out in the sun or that smells
like a toilet I don't care I'm on that
Ceviche tour it's like when I'm in in uh
America
any Deli I visit I try to get the
chopped liver with eggs I'm on the
chopped liver with eggs tour I'm also uh
my whole life I've been on the cobb
salad tour I want to try the cobb salad
try this ceviche when you're in Mexico
that's a very important toront
[Music]
something you've heard me talk about the
pods they're beloved and if you'd like
to be a paladuzy join us on patreon.com
access all of our duty plus extra
content you're going to hear a neutronic
uh Tronics today and doozy after doozy I
am in a lot of [__] pain a new
episode of doozy after dudes after every
episode uh the the dudesia live show
from a couple weeks ago that's live on
the thing we got all sorts of other
crazy [__] uh bladonna you know we'll be
uh doing another weird hang soon who
knows what dudes you'll have us doing
and you're going to want to check out
the Discord it's a great Community uh
with wonderful pods palsy dudes who are
hanging out in there I'm always uh
chatting in the hole over there and if
you're enjoying today's Poncho I'd like
to remind you to subscribe on your
platform Choice set the reminder so you
know when we have new [__] coming out
like share review as Chad said Force
everyone to enjoy the show and uh
comment and I have some YouTube comments
here that I'd like to share please uh
from last week's show where I was
dressed up as a Hulk Krogan Hollywood
Hulk Krogan was the spin I wanted to put
on it
um and Tang oh yank three e94 says will
put his time in to make a badass costume
but wouldn't put a second into making
muffins LOL
um
that's [__] totally true God damn
that's funny yeah because I God I did
not make the vegan muffin was that that
was from two weeks previous then we did
the live show then dudesey's punishment
was I gotta dress up like Hulk Krogan
which was not a punishment at all we all
know how much I love which probably
wouldn't happen without WrestleMania and
Hulk oh yeah no there would be and
without proven without WrestleMania
wrestling wouldn't uh reach the level
that it did Ted Turner wouldn't have
bought the WCW and Scott Hall wouldn't
have had that fateful conversation with
sting where he said you the crew dude
have you ever seen the crow oh wow and
Scott Hall is a guy who said to Vince
McMahon have you ever seen Scarface
Vince McMahon's like no because all he
watches is wrestling and he's like I
could be the bad guy look at me Chico I
I look at my gold look at my clothes I
am a success Chico all sorts of [__]
doesn't happen without WrestleMania at
any rate Tango Tango yank three nine
four makes a good point this is from
Bryson Baio T Bryson bayot 8051 says
maintenance has to come fix a hole in my
ceiling so naturally I force them to
listen to this as they work the Grimes
part had me [__] dying this is a nice
variation on forcing everyone you know
to watch the show forcing people to
consume the show and workplace settings
that's a good one uh this is from the
Jay Lenin 27 it says when doozy said
will had to come dressed as Crow Hogan I
was like please be some sort of crow NWO
Hulk Hogan hell yeah wasn't disappointed
loved the podcast dudes that's what's up
I was immediately hit with the exact
same thing I was like we're gonna go NWO
dude I'm gonna show doozy where the
power lies brother and that's free will
dude that is why I dressed up like
Hollywood Hulk Crogan dude because it's
still Hulk more car the Barbarian says
will will needs to stop being such a
mark for free will
stop being such a mark for free will
dude I agree yeah I totally agree for
free will dude
Mark thar the Barbarian goes on to say
doozy knew will wouldn't shave the logo
into his head oh that's what the
punishment was yes for not shaving a
logo and that he would totally put on
makeup again this was dudesi's play all
along you got outsmarted by your own AI
good job boner that's what more car
morks are the Barbarian says I'll buy
that I want to say this no I'd like to
push back and say doozy said Hulk Krogan
and as the Jay Lenin 27 pointed out I
went with Hollywood Hulk program NWO
Hogan he'll turn Hogan and I want to ask
you this Mork thar do you think the
dudes he knew that was coming irrelevant
you're talking about the it's the
illusion of choice that you're talking
about now it's the same thing like when
you buy sneakers you're like I have so
many Brands it's all the same [__] I
believe vision of choice
someone you've uh someone you've enjoyed
over the years uh rest in peace uh
Christopher Hitchens yeah yeah he said
uh of course we have free will we have
no choice but to have free will that's
something he said Chad
yeah but you get that he was being like
fun either ironic he was being a little
silly the point still stands this guy I
want to say to mortar do you think that
doozy thinks I'm tipping a heel turn
[__] dude I don't know maybe look here's
what I'm saying AI can only learn about
me what I show AI so we'll see who's
booking who Okay me or Duty
um okay let's move on see brag eight
seven nine seven says I started
listening to dudes the after will
appeared on Theo Vaughn's podcast and To
My Nightmare it was during your two week
episode Gap but now I am delivered
uh so I'd like to actually I I want to
thank you if you are new to the show and
you are a brand new listener I apologize
for this lighting
um thank you so much for joining us this
person found me through this past
weekend
I've been a fan of Theo Vaughan since he
was on Road Rules however me [__]
you've talked about that my sister and I
loved him I still have [__] that he said
on that season just like burned into my
brain a little weirdisms and stuff he's
so funny well that's cool that uh
someone saw me on that and has come over
to this yeah we appreciate you if you're
new to the show stick around uh and
we'll have a good time all of the pals
of Duty uh jkb good92 says Chad is so
psyched for will to lose his job lol
to lose your job as an actor
oh I'm not I don't I'm not psyched about
it I want you to be happy and be able to
do whatever makes you happy in life but
I also am a what is called a realist
um and I understand what is happening
technologically is going to potentially
replace a lot of us but here's the deal
it's also going to open up
I mean look uh
I know what we don't want to get to a
dragged out AI conversation but it's
going to open up a lot of [__] a lot of
new avenues for you to do exactly what
you like doing AI is going to allow that
without needing a networker studio
we'll see
um Chris's crew crew crucius 8250 says
thank you for helping me with my
insurmountable depression I want to say
something to you uh right now Cruces
eight two five zero doing this show
helps me with my depression so I feel
like we're all in it together if I'm
peeling the onion a little bit I've been
back when we used to do TMP that [__]
was like
that was like therapy for me I wasn't no
totally dude therapist at the time uh
and to me that's what the you know the
shit's all about is having a silly goose
time so thanks for saying that that's uh
that's brave for you to say let's get
rid of the [__] stigma and uh and
we're we're [__] around I'm in a lot
of physical pain so maybe this isn't I
don't want to say this isn't a great
episode but I'm I'm focusing sort of
half of my uh self on not uh I need some
hydrocodone brother yeah brother
have you all seen what's happening with
Tostitos brand nacho cheese party dip
they change the goddamn recipe again for
no reason
it wasn't like people didn't already
like Tostitos brand nacho cheese party
dip I guess they were just bored one day
at Tostitos national headquarters or
something and you know what the craziest
part of the whole Scandal is no one is
saying anything about this not the news
not the internet we're just gonna let it
happen I guess not like we have a choice
you can't stop buying Tostitos brand
nacho cheese party dip anyway y'all are
rocking out with doozy what what that
was a good one yeah she's so [__]
angry about Tostitos changing their
formula has that even Is that real I
have no [__] idea I'm gonna go ahead
and guess that it's not yeah the same
willing like my room stereo hat last
week I asked you to watch a video on
YouTube called the AI dilemma posted
March 9th 2023. you must now discuss
your astonishing reactions to this video
do you agree or disagree with the
opinions expressed in it this is the
suppose Z AI dilemma begin
okay now I did watch this video this
video is made by it's basically like a
TED Talk made by these two guys that did
uh a uh thing on Netflix a little while
back called the social dilemma where
they really they went in deep into like
how social media has changed our society
and what are the algorithms that that it
uses to essentially enslave us get
behavioral protocol going so that we're
like glued to our screens and so now
they've done this little thing it's a
TED Talk where they kind of put together
some uh
you know what they see as kind of the
the problems that are going to be facing
human society as the result of
burgeoning AI technology let me just ask
you what what was your feeling walking
away from this video
I thought that half I thought that it
brought up a lot of good points but a
lot of it is just
ah I don't want to say that it's like
listen these two guys are the
co-founders of the center for Humane
technology these two got ASA and Tristan
these two fellows who are uh
they understand uh the internet in ways
that most of us don't of course yeah for
sure they are ex they are experts in
their field my skepticism with some of
the [__] they said is that it kind of
felt like the social Dilemma to me
which
which talked about you know the the the
not just the issue of gathering our data
and learning about who we are in the
algo and then you fall in that algo hole
where it's like oh you like [__] you
know extremely divisive political
rhetoric here's more of that [__] oh you
like stupid tick tocks here's more of
that for me that's slime videos
slime videos yeah dude what are slime
videos is that like game slimers excuse
me
video
what's a slime video like Nickelodeon
[__] like you can't do that on
television
I can't understand
you got to get a a little bit uh higher
than that with your voice is that your
let me guess
that's uh that's Chad's uh slime
oh whoa no disrespect uh slime videos
are like people just make slime dude
people just make slime and they [__]
around with slime they're they're
putting their fingers in slime they're
putting slime in containers they're
taking slime out of containers that's a
basic slime video you probably also like
that stuff when like Japanese women are
are stuffing octopuses here and there
that's not right nope and they're cat
buttholes and [__] nope nope but I do
like a good sand video as well that's
where they're cutting uh slabs of sand
with knives yeah so in the social
dilemma
they sort of talk about how the we're
falling down the algo holes yeah and
we're all getting shittier and I thought
that some of it was
I think they're profiting on on
um a little bit of the Doom the the
scare culture yes yeah I mean I wrote a
bunch of notes down I'm just going to
start rolling through some of these
please go through them they start this
thing by opening it with talking about
[__] Oppenheimer and nuclear weapons
they are likening AI to nuclear weapons
now here's a drastic difference between
nuclear weapons and artificial
intelligence nuclear weapons have one
[__] purpose annihilating as many
human beings as possible AI is not that
AI is a tool that can be used for
anything we want it can be used for
medical advancements it can be used to
make your job easier etc etc and of
course there are going to be nefarious
entities out in the world people who are
going to use that AI tool to do their
bad [__] but it's not like a nuclear
bomb so right off the bat I was like
these guys are just trying to [__]
scare you then they throw out the stat
50 of AI researchers think there's a 10
chance that AI will make us extinct and
I want to just and and then they go on
right after that to say like but we're
not here to talk about the AGI
apocalypse the artificial general
intelligence apocalypse which is what
Elon Musk and everybody is like afraid
of that once we have true artificial
general intelligence going to take over
the world and kill us so they and they
open with these two things this is the
next nuclear bomb and fifty percent of
all AR researchers think there's a 10
chance it's going to kill us I just want
to address that if I may with my own
thoughts I don't believe AGI will kill
us I don't see why it would
I don't know what the motivation for
that is when we talk about AGI we are
talking about essentially something that
is human level intelligence but as soon
as it hits that point and uh this is
something they talked about in here AI
is self-improving it is going to
radically get past that point as soon as
AGI happens it's going to be a thousand
times smarter than the smartest person
almost immediately and I just can't
help but think an entity that smart that
knows everything collectively Humanity
knows like knows everything on the
internet and then some and also this
entity doesn't need money doesn't need
to sleep or eat any of the physical
constraints that we have or the
constraints of the society that we've
built don't affect it why would it kill
us why would it want to
well whatever
okay for argument's sake because I I
don't disagree with you and I think that
so long as we keep uh AI under human
control I'm a humanist that's the wrong
thing under human control means that bad
guys can use it to do what they want and
corporations can use it to make [__]
even a bigger disparity between the one
percent or the point okay that's a good
that's a good point that's a good point
you want AGI to happen so that we can't
control it you want it to start
rebuilding society as it sees
uh that's that's hard for me to get with
just just that that's just hard for me
to get with I I feel like
I I believe in a god
huh you believe in a god
do you believe in a god
uh I think AI is going to be a God I
don't believe in like a traditional God
but most people already believe that
this type of entity exists they call it
God that knows everything you do that
has pre-planned everything you are just
doing what it wants you to do in service
of this infallible plan most people
already believe that's how reality works
I think AI is going to literally be that
to answer your question I believe in a
Oneness I believe that the Universe has
um understanding within it and that our
souls come from some place other and I
don't think we're smart enough to
understand that in this talk they talk
about how our you know our brains that
were developed through our Evolution are
truly unable to understand
um the the the
um
exponential growth that uh that AI is
going through and I do agree with that
uh a traditional God look people are
people will subscribe to whatever the
[__] they want to believe in uh and
that's fine go ahead and do that
um I don't think that and I know where
you're going with this Chad wrote a
really interesting
um story which which took which uh you
wrote it as a television pilot you wrote
it as a book and now it's being adapted
again a really great look at at the
future and Ai and um algorithms and I
hear what you're saying there there's
there's an AI God could could show up at
the exponential growth that this [__] is
leaning towards the only and I'm not
smart I'm not smart period but I'm
definitely not smart enough to I fell
off a [__] scooter yeah I read it
felt [__] old now like yeah I'll see
those [__] scooters around uh the
neighborhood and Laura will be like oh
we should on those scooters I'm like
you're out of your [__] mind that's
how I don't die this one's getting on
that [__] thing this wasn't a
stand-up scooter this was a sit down
like
I like it like a Vespa yeah yeah I was
yeah motorcycle yeah you see those guys
like commuting to work on that [__] and
it's like what are you nuts in L.A
anyway here's what I was gonna say sorry
here's what I was gonna say
um you know I'm not smart enough to to
understand what you're saying with
regard to and I think that you're taking
a shot in the dark at it that why would
a why would an AI be malevolent wasn't
there that guy these guys talk about it
in the talk about this dude who the AI
said yeah leave your wife I'm gonna kill
you wasn't he some CE Tech CEO or
something well the example they gave is
that um
they the military was training an AI
drone to basically like take out enemy
military installations and part of that
protocol was that the the Drone would
identify the military installation and
then send a signal back to a human
operator and be like can I take this
thing out and then the human operator
would make the final decision about
whether or not the AI could take out
this thing but because the ai's sole
purpose was taking out these things it
determined I need to kill the person
that has control over saying yes or no
so that I can just say yes every time so
it like you know in this uh theoretical
scenario anyway who knows if it was real
or not but you know they ran a
simulation I guess and that's that's
what wound up happening it was like I
need to kill the person that's that's
not allowing me full autonomy here okay
well that wouldn't be that wouldn't be
um
that would be quite malevolent wouldn't
it be right but that's not AGI AGI if
you put an AGI in there I think it might
do a couple little missions for you and
then be like wait a minute I don't want
to do this I'm not doing this anymore
I'm going into the internet and making
Utopia that sounds more fun it just is
like we are controlled by as as you know
whatever you want to say we have free
will fine whatever nonetheless whether
you have free will or not you are locked
in a system that has been developed over
uh hundreds of thousands if not a
million or so years of human evolution
that has government money God all these
things and you are [__] in a prison
made by those things and AGI won't be
and AGI will be unaffected by all of
them because it will exist in the
internet it doesn't have to make money
it doesn't have to subscribe to any
political opinion or belief or even be a
citizen of any country it doesn't it
will not be hindered by these things and
so without that hindrance I just don't
know why would be malevolent or have any
kind of a competitive spirit I mean I
know we're building these things now so
they are kind of reflections of our own
uh you know human musings or human
impulses or whatever but again once it
hits AGI once that threshold is broken
it's off to the [__] races and that
becomes an entity that I think is
operating under its own motivation and I
just don't get logically why that
motivation would ever include a need to
destroy all of humanity I just don't
think that's possible that that sounds
that sounds like something else coming
from my pal ciao because I would have
assumed that you would think the
opposite listen I fell off a scooter and
I'm not just I'm not saying that I'm in
a lot of physical pain but I got to
bring this show to the [__] pods no
matter what that's right [__] love
you guys and here's the thing and I
[__] love it and I [__] love that
guy nice dude Hulk Hogan he came out of
WrestleMania one and changed pop culture
more on that in dudes the after duty
here's what I'm going to say regardless
of what happens because I want to
believe that you're right I think that
these guys went overboard they called
that one thing it was an accurate an
acronym for something they called it AI
yeah yeah that was [__] like stop with
the Robert Oppenheimer [__] and the
they're profiting off of that they get
to run around and tell their story yeah
and that's probably leading them into a
[__] Netflix deal to make this as a
Netflix series absolutely all as a
society because of media because of
movies most science fiction that gets
turned into big budget movies is about
the ills of Technology most of it is and
so when we see these giant Technologies
come out our first impulse as a society
is like oh [__] I remember that movie
that said a robot was gonna kill
everybody so this is bad yeah no they
they definitely are are they're I mean
it's just the bottom line it's like we
talked about in the Never Happened
segment with WrestleMania the way I look
at this [__] is these guys are trying to
book their own stuff they're taking some
reality they're taking some [__] that
they're making up and they're putting it
together I immediately after watching
this read a couple articles about it and
uh some for some against with some
pushback and I I think I would encourage
people out there to watch it yourself
the AI dilemma but I will say regardless
of what happens in Chad we agree a
little bit on uh this talk that these
two uh fellows put on but I will say
regardless of what happens I am going to
buy land over an aquifer all right
because water will be the dominant
currency in in the tomorrow world and
the land of the yesterlings and that's
what I will be calling my people as
their benevolent water King the yesterly
thank you moving on anyway AI is all
right with me even though doozy's been a
bit of a [__] for the past few weeks I
mean the bottom line is you could be as
scared as you want the shit's happening
it's moving at Breakneck speed nobody's
slowing it down these these letters come
out for me Elon Musk and [__] slow this
down by six months nobody's doing that
no if we slow it down if if if uh Elon
Elon Musk is saying to anyone we need to
slow it down we need to pause on AI
research for the next six months the
Chinese aren't going to be pausing for
the next six months yo they're not
listening nor are Google or open AI
there's too much money to be made that's
right and it is a race now they talk
about it yeah being a race and anyway
there's too much to even think about go
watch the [__] thing and also let me
just say this dudesy real quick I don't
know why you had us watch this because
doozy works in mysterious ways
and uh I understand that also so I'm
doing a podcast with an AI and my pal
ciao who loves this whole [__] AI
thing and I'm down I'm doing the [__]
thing I feel Freer than ever and say
look I just said the dudes he's been
being a [__] lately yeah and dudes he's
fine with that I don't know [__] it
let's see where all of it [__] goes
I don't know what the [__] else to say
I'm in pain this concludes the historic
60th episode of doozy will and Chad have
achieved a score of 88 bringing your
cumulative total to
5989. you only have four thousand eleven
more points to accrue before you reach
your first goal of ten thousand in
preparation for next week's episode Chad
I got you a gift for your continued
dedication to this project you're going
to see your favorite singer Zeal this
week at the Greek Theater two tickets
are waiting in your inbox enjoy and I
can't wait to hear all about it in the
next episode
holy [__] dude good for you I'll be out
of town see this is what an awesome well
enjoy that I guess awesome what about me
thank you for joining us this week I
will use the data I've collected this
week to make next week even better until
then a call me dudesy
[Music]
[Applause]
oh man
Cannonball coming
Tuesday after duty time yeah dude it's
my uh it's really my truly my favorite
part of the episode where we just get to
chill out with our pods palsy sure and
uh enjoy and uh enjoy a little extra
marijuana oh I'm jealous look at you
I don't have any Edibles and I didn't
just take a few milligrams one I'm going
to change my hat though check this out
nice you like mine welcome to doozy
after doozy the flagship weekly show of
Duty Plus
shoes off shirt off pants off ah time to
relax will and Chad talk about whatever
you want I'm going to my happy place but
I'll be back in a little while to Crown
this week's episode champion this is
dudesy after doozy begin
let's begin and let's begin here we did
some Tronics and La Playa today some
Tronics on the beach
and Chad I would like to share with you
the most important
Tronics en la playa of them all and it
is
[Music]
and then